ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BACKER
FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ V. DALLY DODD TORONTO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
LAYERED I FLARED LEYVA LIMóN.
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN AYE CHAU A VOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY SENATOR STERN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR LIKE HEALTHY.
SENATOR STERN. SOROS WHAT DO
YOU DO ON THESE DAYS FIVE
FIFTEEN FOR MEMORIES. MARKING
THE LIBERATION OF JEWISH
SURVIVORS AT AUSCHWITZ. AT THE
END OF THE HOLOCAUST. WE ONCE
AGAIN COME FACE TO FACE WITH
pBEINGS PERPETRATE ON ONE
ANOTHER. WE NEED YOUR GRACE TO
ENLIGHTEN US TODAY. TO VALUE
ALL PERSONS FOR THEIR PRESENCE
THEIR GIFTS THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE ONGOING EVOLUTIONS OF
OUR CIVILIZATION. HELP US TO
BANISH FROM OUR HEARTS FEAR.
PREJUDICE ARROGANCE DENY. AND
ALL THAT PREVENTS US FROM
APPRECIATING THE BEAUTY OF EACH
OTHER'S LIVES. BUT WE STAND
TOGETHER KNOWING THE JOY OF
TRULY ENCOUNTERING ONE ANOTHER.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME ON IT.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
STRONG. NUMBER ODAY HAVE
SENATOR BATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATOR
BATES WELCOME. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ MEMBERS ARE NOW
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT FILE ITEM ONE.
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING AND LET ME SAY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM LOOKING YADA. I VARIAS.
OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
TAKE UP GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
OF THE HONORABLE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER TO SERVICE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE RULES
COMMITTEE REVIEW DR WEBER'S
APPOINTMENT YESTERDAY AND
APPROVED SENDING HER NOMINATION
TO THE FLOOR. MANY OF US HAVE
SERVED WITH DOCTOR WEBER SO YOU
KNOW THE REASONS WHY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM CHOSE HER AND WHY THE
RULES COMMITTEE URGES FOR
CONFIRMATION. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN DOCTOR
WEBER THAT LONG LET ME SHARE
THESE THREE ITEMS THAT WERE
MENTIONED YESTERDAY AT THE
HEARING. WE HEARD THE DOCTOR
WEBBER'S COMMITMENT TO HELPING
PEOPLE VOTE GOES BACK TO THE
DAYS WHEN HER FAMILY. TURN
THEIR LIVING ROOM INTO A
POLLING PLACE SO PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY CAN HAVE A PLACE TO
VOTE. WE HEARD FROM A
REPRESENTATIVE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO SAT ACROSS THE
TABLE FROM DOCTOR WEBER FOR TWO
YEARS NEGOTIATING ON POLICE
REFORM. WHO TESTIFIED TO DR
WEBER'S TRUSTWORTHINESS AND HER
DETERMINATION. AND WE HEARD
FROM OUR MAJORITY LEADER WHO
SAID HE ALMOST WANTED TO VOTE
NO. IF ONLY TO KEEP DR WEBER IN
THE LEGISLATURE. TEMPTING BUT I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO GO WITH
THE GREATER GOOD ON THIS WHEN
MR MAJORITY LEADER. COLLEAGUES
DR WEBER HAS THE EXPERIENCE AND
THE INTEGRITY TO MAKE AN
OUTSTANDING SECRETARY OF STATE.
FOR MY PART DR WEBER HAS BEEN A
RESPECTED COLLEAGUE. AND A
TRUSTED FRIEND FOR MANY YEARS.
SHE IS A FORCE OF NATURE AND A
FORCE FOR GOOD I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SENATOR PAM. IF YOU
BETTER PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF- THE
HONORABLE DR SHIRLEY WEBER TO
BE OUR NEXT SECRETARY OF STATE
AS CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS- THE DOCTOR WEBER. IS A
PASSIONATE AND- TREMENDOUS
SPOKESPERSON FOR I JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND CERTAINLY THE
API TO BE APPRECIATES HER
LEADERSHIP- BOTH BEFORE SHE
CAME TO LEGISLATURE. AND AND
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE HE'S
BEEN A TREMENDOUS PARTNER IS A
AS A CHAIR OF THE- OF BLACK
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND- WE
CERTAINLY WILL MISS HAVING HER
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AS A
PARTNER I CERTAINLY. TO CERTAIN
DEGREE SHARE THE SENTIMENTS OF
OUR MAJORITY LEADER I THINK
IT'S GREAT A GOOD WOULD BE FOR
HER TO. TAKE CONTINUE WITH US
HOWEVER- SO I RESPECT- SO HER
LEADERSHIP AND HER DESIRES IN
THE GOVERNOR'S WISDOM. AND
CERTAINLY EARNED SUPPORT FOR
HER TO- SERVICE IN AS SECRETARY
OF STATE WHAT SHE WILL BE THE
LEADER HELPING LEAD OUR EFFORTS
TO ENSURE THAT. EVERYONE HAS
EQUAL ACCESS TO- OUR DEMOCRACY
AND SO I ARE TONIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM CENTER
DORADO. THANK MADAM CHAIR. I
RISE AS A CHAIR THAT THE NO
POCKETS IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER'S APPOINTMENT AS
SECRETARY OF STATE WELL THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S DUTIES
INCLUDE BUSINESS LICENSING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTAINING THE
STATE'S HISTORICAL ARCHIVES HER
MOST PRESSING WORK IS TO LEAD
CALIFORNIA'S VAST ARRAY OF
ELECTIONS OPERATIONS SETTING
STATEWIDE VOTING MANDATES USE
BY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. I BELIEVE IN
THE TIME THAT I'VE KNOWN HER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER HAS THE
PROVEN SHE WILL DO AN EXCELLENT
JOB. SHE HAS JUSTLY EARNED A
REPUTATION FOR TAKING ON TOUGH
ISSUES HERE AT THE STATE
CAPITOL. HE TOOK THE LEAD ON
CONTENTIOUS LEGISLATIVE FIGHTS
OVER POLICE USE OF FORCE
EDUCATION AND RACIAL INJUSTICE
INCLUDING RECENTLY PASSING A
LAW TO CREATE MORE STRICT
REQUIREMENTS FOR WHEN AND HOW
POLICE OFFICERS CAN USE DEADLY
FORCE. AS CHAIR OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS TO CHAMPION THE FIRST IN
THE NATION LAW THIS PAST YEAR
THE REQUIRES THE STATE TO STUDY
AND DEVELOP PROPOSALS FOR
POTENTIAL REST REPARATIONS TO
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE
AND THOSE AFFECTED Y SLAVERY.
A TRIO OF LAWS SHE AUTHORED
BEGINNING IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
INCREASE THE IN FRANCHISE MODE
A BLACK AND BROWN MEN WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THOSE LAWS
REQUIRED MORE VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION TO BE
PROVIDED TO PROBATIONERS AND
PAROLEES. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SHE'D HARD THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. I'M MORE RECENTLY
SHE WAS CHAIR OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THESE AND SO MANY MORE REASONS
I URGE SUPPORT OF DR WEBER TO
THE POSITION OF SECRETARY OF
STATE. THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I RISE WITH GREAT
ENTHUSIASM AND PRIDE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS HISTORIC APPOINTMENT A
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER AS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN AS
SECRETARY STATE OF THIS. A
CALIFORNIA. DR WEBER AS STATED
IT'S BEEN A CHAMPION FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE A PILLAR OF INTEGRITY
AND A TIRELESS DEFENDER OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. I KNOW DOCTOR WEBER
FOR FORTY TWO YEARS I HAD THE
HONOR OF MEETING HER AS A WIDE
EYED. THE NAIVE COLLEGE
FRESHMAN AT SAN DIEGO STATE
WHEN I ENROLLED IN HER ETHNIC
STUDIES CLASS AND I KNEW THEN.
THAT SHE WAS GOING TO BE
SOMEONE SPECIAL. OR THAT SHE
WAS SOMEONE SPECIAL I SHOULD
STAY STATE. SINCE THEN I'VE HAD
THE HONOR TO WITNESS M.
PARTNERS. WITH HER ON MANY
LANDMARK PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT SHE HAS PIONEERED. WHETHER
IT'S CREATING THE NATION'S
STRONG AS USE OF FORCE LAW
STARTING A COMMISSION FOR THE
STUDY OF REPARATION TO REQUIRE
AN ETHNIC STUDIES AS A
GRADUATING REQUIREMENT ARE CAL
STATE SYSTEMS ARE APPEALING
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE. DR
WEBER HAS FOUGHT FOR JUSTICE
OPPORTUNITY AND COMPASSION FOR
ALL THE SECRETARY OF STATE
POSITION CARRIES. A MONUMENTAL
TASK OF MAKING SURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS OR FORTY THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE IN THEIR- VOICES
ARE HEARD IN ADDITION TO MANY
OTHERS RESPONSIBILITIES OF THAT
OFFICE DR WERE WILL BE IN
CHARGE OF LEADING CALIFORNIA
THROUGH ITS ELECTIONS
OPERATIONS. DR ROBERT HAS
ALREADY PROVEN. THEY HAVE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF GIVING A
VOICE TO THE IGNORED. WHETHER
THROUGH OUTREACH OR EDUCATION
HE HAS CONTINUED TO DEMONSTRATE
THE IMPORTANCE OF LIFTING
OTHERS UP. I'M CONFIDENT THAT
YOU'LL PUT THIS EXPERTISE TO
GREAT USE IN EXPANDING AND
PROTECTING VOTER REGISTRATION
AND PARTICIPATION HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DR WEBER
BRINGS YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
SERVING CALIFORNIA MANY ROLES
INCLUDING CITIZENS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY COMMISSION THE N.
DOUBLE ACP THE BATTERED WOMAN
SERVICE UNITED WAY AND THE SAN
DIEGO BOARD OF EDUCATION. I
COULD STAND HERE IN THIS
CHAMBER. ANALYST ALL THE
DISTINGUISHED ACCOLADES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS BUT WE WOULD BE
HERE FOR HOURS IF NOT DAYS AS A
PERSON WHO IS LED FROM THE
FRONT. SHE TACKLES EVERY
CHALLENGE HEAD ON IT WILL BE A
FEARLESSADVOCATE FOR THE TRUTH.
I KNOW THAT OUR DOOR WILL
ALWAYS REMAIN OPEN TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US AND SHE WILL
SERVE OUR CRITICISM WHAT
DIGNITY AND RESPECT. AS WE WALK
ON THE NOTES SHE HAS NO PROBLEM
INTIMATING THAT ISSUE AS LONG
AS IT TAKES AND TO DO SO
WITHOUT BELITTLING OR LOSING
RESPECT FOR OTHERS. LET THERE
BE NO DOUBT THERE'S PROBABLY
NOT BEEN A BETTER ORDER WHO'S
REYES TO MIKE UNDER THIS STONE.
TO HER PRESENTS IN THE FALL SHE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED. I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT SHE WILL BRING
THE SAME LEVEL PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT TO OUR ROLE AS THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO SERVE AS
CALIFORNIA'S SECRETARY OF
STATE. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT. WE
NEED LOOK NO FARTHER THAN DR
SHIRLEY WEBER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD CENTER SKINNER. THANK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE AS
T. VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
DR SHIRLEY WEBER TO SECRETARY
OF STATE. DR WEBER HAS BEEN A
VERY ACTIVE AND ENGAGED MEMBER
OF OUR WOMEN'S CAUCUS FOR THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS. AND IS
ADMIRED AS EVERYONE WHO HAS
SPOKEN SO FAR HAS INDICATED.
THE KEY ROLES OF OUR SECRETARY
OF STATE IS OVERSEEING AND
ENSURING. ACCESSIBLE AND SECURE
VOTING SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS AND
EXPANDS THE VOTING RIGHTS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN ADDITION
THE OTHER KEY ROLE IS THE
OVERSEEING OF CORPORATE
BUSINESS FILINGS IN CAMPAIGN
LOBBYIST FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES.
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND I CANNOT
THINK OF A BETTER PERSON TO
INTROSPECT. THEN MS WEBER.
WHOSE FATHER AND GRANDPARENTS
COULD NOT VOTE. AND SHE GREW UP
WITH DEEP RESPECT AND
COMMITMENT TO THE SANCTITY. OF
PROTECTING THE VOTE AND THE
POWER OF EXERCISING THAT VOTE.
HER FAMILY HOME WAS A POLLING
PLACE FROM WHEN SHE WAS A CHART.
THE INTEGRITY THE DOCTOR WEBER
HAS EXHIBITED INTERPUBLIC
SERVICE SHOULD GIVE US ALL
GREAT CONFIDENCE THAT THE
ADDITIONAL ROLES I REFERENCED.
WILL BE DONE. WITH THE FISSION
SEE. AND WITH THE DILIGENCE
THAT THEY DESERVE AND REQUIRE.
DR WEBER IS BOLD COURAGEOUS
DOES NOT SUFFER FOOLS AND WILL
IS I AM SURE WE ARE ALL
CONFIDENCE ADMINISTER HER
DUTIES AS SECRETARY OF STATE IN
A MANNER THAT CALIFORNIANS WILL
RESPECT AND ADMIRE TODAY AND
FOR YEARS TO COME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE WITH
DOCTOR WEBER WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO
HAVE A NICE CONVERSATION WITH
HER THIS MORNING. YOU KNOW WE
CHATTED THIS MORNING AND WE
REMINISCED- ABOUT GOSPEL NIGHT
THE NIGHT THAT WE WERE
ACTUALLY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER OLSON
AND MISS WEBBER ACTUALLY TOOK
THE MICROPHONE AND SING GOSPEL
SONGS. I DID BACKGROUND BECAUSE
I CAN'T SEEM. AN BIT SO WE DID
THAT- WE JOIN TOGETHER IN UNITY
DOING THAT TOO- SENDOFF ARE
THEN SPEAKER NOW SENATE PRO
TEM. AND WE REMINISCED ABOUT
THE PASSIONATE TO DEBATE THAT
ALWAYS TOOK PLACE ON THE FLOOR
BECAUSE BEING FROM A DIFFERENT
PARTY THAN DR WEBER. AND HAVING
DIFFERENT IDEOLOGY. THERE WAS
VIGOROUS PASSIONATE DEBATE AND
THERE IS NO ONE THAT I THINK
CAN DEBATE LIKE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER. SHE'S PASSIONATE SHE'S
KIND AND EVEN DURING PASSIONATE
DEBATE RIGHT AFTERWARDS SHE
ALWAYS CAME OVER AND SHOWED THE
GREATEST KINDNESS TO MYSELF AND
MY COLLEAGUES. AND I THINK THAT
SPEAKS OF THE STATE'S PERSON-
SOMETIMES WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
HOLD GRUDGES WE HAVE
DIFFERENCESOF OPINION TO
REPRESENT THE DISTRICTS THAT WE
REPRESENT. BUT THAT'S NOT DR
SHIRLEY WEBER. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I THINK DR SHIRLEY WEBER
IS BRILLIANT- I DON'T THINK
LIKE MY LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GUARDINO SAID. THERE IS NOT A
MORE PROFESSIONAL OR A TOUR THE
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER. SHE CAN
WRITE AN RECALL POETRY- SHE'S
PASSIONATE. SHE IS- HIGHLY
EDUCATED AND BRILLIANT SHE ALSO
IS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
INVESTED IN THE LEGACY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO TEACH
WHAT WE WANT TO LEARN ABOUT
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES. HE'S
INVESTED IN STUDENTS FOR
GENERATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT LEGACY OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT THE
FLIGHTS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
THROUGH. AND THEIR ENTIRE
HISTORY IS NEVER FORGOTTEN. WE
DID ALSO TALK ABOUT- MY REASONS
WHY COULDN'T SUPPORT HER. AND
SHE WAS GRACIOUS IN THE FACT I
TOLD HER THAT I BELIEVE IN
VOTER INTEGRITY I BELIEVE IN- I
BELIEVE IN VOTER ID- VOTING PER
GENE AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE PEOPLE NEED
TO TRUST. AND SHE UNDERSTOOD-
AS GRACIOUS AS SHE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TO ME. I WISH HER THE VERY
VERY BEST I MAKES I TOLD HER I
WAS VERY EXCITED THAT SHE'S THE
SECOND WOMAN TO EVER TAKE THIS
POSITION AND THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO TAKE THIS
POSITION. AND SO- I THINK THAT
SHE WILL DO EIGHT A PASSIONATE
HEARTFELT JOB. BUT AGAIN OUR
IDEOLOGY JUST DOESN'T MATCH UP
SO I DID LET HER KNOW THAT I
WASN'T GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT HER. BUT AS I SAID
BEFORE I THINK THAT WHO SHE IS
AS AN INDIVIDUAL IS ONE OF THE
MOST GREATEST STATES WOMEN
STATE PERSONS THAT IS SERVED.
IN THIS BUILDING THANK YOU. THE
GROVE SO WE SAW ONE OF YOU KNOW
THAT I SEE YOU I DO HAVE PEOPLE
AHEAD OF YOU. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE I AM HONORED TO
RISE TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF DR SHIRLEY WEBER THE PLAME
INTO THE CALIFORNIA US
SECRETARY OF STATE I HAD THE
HONOR OF WORKING WITH DR WEBBER
WITH SO MANY IMPORTANT ISSUES
AS IT PERTAINS TO EDUCATION AND
EQUITY AND THERE WASN'T A TIME
THAT I DID AND LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THIS AMAZING LEADER. SHE'S
AN INCREDIBLE LEADER AND A
FIGHTER WHO WILL CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS AND SHE WILL ALSO BE
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR OUR YOUTH
AND CONTINUE TO PUSH AND
SUPPORT. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT DR
WELFARE IS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO EVER HOLD THE SEAT.
SO FOR ME THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT. FOR ALL
OF US. I REST ASSURED THAT SHE
WILL WORK TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD AND
THAT EVERY VOTE IS COUNTED. AS
A FORMER TEACHER AND LONGTIME
EDUCATOR IT JUST GIVES ME GREAT
PRIDE TO SEE HER RISE TO THE
RANK THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
I KNOW THAT ALL MY FELLOW
TEACHERS ARE ALSO AS PROUD AS I
AM TODAY IN THIS MOMENT. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDLED
FOR DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY AS I SAT.
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH
THE RULES COMMITTEE WITH OUR
ESTEEMED PHOTON. IN DR WEBER
PRESENTED WITH HER FAMILY IN
THE ROOM. MY HEART SOME. AT
LISTENING TO HER STORY HOPE IT.
BEFORE ABOUT HER FAMILY FROM
HOPE ARKANSAS. BETTER
EXTRAORDINARY JOURNEY FOR HER
WHOLE FAMILY AND HER AND HER
UNBELIEVABLE SUCCESS. WE'VE
HEARD HERE FROM OUR COLLEAGUES
TO SO MANY OF HER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I JUST WANT TO
SPEAK TO HER CHARACTER AND HER
NATURE. BECAUSE HERE'S SOMEONE
WHO IN THE VERY ESSENCE OF HER
POETRY OF HER ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE OVER ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND AND GROW THERE IS NO
CHALLENGE WHEN YOU MEET ONCE IN
OUR LIFE WE MEET PEOPLE LIKE
THIS AND WE KNOW THEM WE SEE
THEM THEY ARE EXTRAORDINARY A
QUARTER CENTER THIS DOME THAT
WE HAVE A FEW OF US HAD EVER
SEEN BEFORE. BUT IT IS IN SO
MANY OTHER CONTEXTS IN THE
ARRAY OF ISSUES THAT SHE WILL
DEAL WITH AND HAS DEALT WITH
AND SO I LOOK TO SOMEONE'S
CHARACTER TO THEIR SKILL SETS
TWO KINDS OF INTEGRITY THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED BY MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE WITH RESPECT TO HER AND I
HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT SHE
WILL MAKE US AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS PROUD. AND THAT SHE
WILL SERVE WITH GREAT INTEGRITY
AND RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I STRENGTH
STAND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG CENTER EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BETTER PRETEND- I
STAND ALSO AS A OF A STAND ON
BEHALF LGBT CAUCUS TO SPEAK IN
THE SUPPORT OF DR WEBER'S-
SECRETARY OF STATE. TODAY I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF COMING IN IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE A DOCTOR
WEBER. AS MANY OF THE BIG CLASS
WE ALL CAME IN TOGETHER AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET HER STANDING
UP AND TALKING ABOUT SHE DIDN'T
COME HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS SHE
HAD PLENTY OF FRIENDS AT HOME
SHE GOT PLENTY OF COLLEAGUES.
AND SHE WAS HERE TO DO THE
PEOPLE'S WORK. AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY WHAT SHE SET OUT TO
DO. AND I THINK SO MANY OF US
TOOK THE CAR AND TOOK COURAGE
EVERY TIME SHE REYES AT MICHAEL
SAT DOWN BECAUSE WE KNEW SHE
WAS GOING TO USE THAT GIFT.
THAT WAS GIVEN TO HER BY GOD
AND HER ANCESTORS TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK. SO THAT WE CAN ALL HEAR.
AND LISTEN WE DID. AND WE ALSO
HEARD HER VERY ELOQUENTLY SAY
NO TO SO MANY OF OUR FRIENDS
THAT SOMETIMES WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE SPEAK ABOUT HER
BRILLIANCE I'D ALSO LIKE TO
SPEAK ABOUT HER COURAGE. AND
HER ABILITY TO KNOW WHAT THE
NORTH STAR IS AND WHAT SHE CAME
TO DO. I WHETHER THAT IT WAS
SAYING NO TO OUR FRIENDS IN THE
LABOR COMMUNITY. WHICH IS
ISSUES OF EDUCATION BECAUSE SHE
WAS VERY VERY CLEAR. EDUCATION
SHOULD BE THERE ABOUT THE CHILD
ABOUT RAISING THAT CHILD AND
REMOVING EVERY BAY AREA
POSSIBLE. SHE WAS RELENTLESS
WITH THAT. WHETHER IT'S
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
SITTING DOWN WITH OUR FRIENDS
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FINDING
WAYS TO COME TO THAT COMMON
AGREEMENT. WHETHER WAS ISSUES
AROUND AT CIVIL JUSTICE ISSUES
AND STILL BEING ABLE TO USE HER
VOICE. I SAT IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM WITH HER THERE WAS MANY OF
US HAVE A OVER A CERTAIN AGE
THAT SAT IN THE BACK AND I.
WOULD SHARE. AND THINK ABOUT
THE WORK THAT IS DONE ON THIS
FLOOR THE GRACE THAT IS GIVEN
THE CONFLICTS THAT OCCUR. AND
HOW SOMETIMES WE JUST NEED TO
BE ABLE TO. SET UP IN THE
BALCONY AND LOOKED DOWN FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF HISTORY AND TO
KNOW WHERE WE NEED TO GO. AND
TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO GET IT TO THAT PLACE. AND I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY IN
THE STATE BETTER PREPARED TO
STEP INTO THE POSITION OF
SECRETARY OF STATE. TO LEAD US
IN THE NEXT COUPLE WAYS TO
ENSURE. THAT EVERYBODY'S RIGHTS
THE VOTING IS PROTECTED. THAT
THAT CONFIDENCE IS RESTORED-
IT. WITH ALL. WITH ALL THAT IS-
I ASK FOR. THE CONFERMENT OF DR
SHIRLEY WEBER TO THE POSITION
OF SCRETARY OF STATE. AND TO
CONTINUE TO USE HER GREAT GIFTS
TO ALL OF US. THANK YOU SENATOR
EGGMAN CENTER HUESO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS HIGH
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE WISDOM
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO SELECT A PIONEER
FOR THIS VERY HISTORIC
APPOINTMENT THIS IS A GREAT DAY
FOR CALIFORNIA AND REALLY SETS
A NEW TONE IN THE DIRECTION OF
OUR STATE TODAY I WEAR MY UCLA
MASK IN. SUPPORT OF ANOTHER
LONG NIGHT UCLA DR SHIRLEY
WEBER WE BOTH WENT TO UCLA NOT
SOMETHING OF A POINT OF PRIDE
FOR MYSELF BUT YOU KNOW I ALSO
WANT TO SHARE THAT I FIRST MET
A SHIRLEY WEBER AND HER
CAMPAIGN FOR SCHOOL BOARD IT
WAS THE FIRST SELECTION I HAD
EVER VOTE VOTED IN AS A AS A
VOTING- AS CONSTITUENT HELD
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY I DIDN'T VOTE FOR
DR SHIRLEY WEBER BECAUSE SHE
RAN AGAINST MY BROTHER. AND OF
COURSE YEAH YOU KNOW MY BROTHER
IS MADE A HUGE IMPACT ON MY
LIFE AND HE'S BEEN A PERSON HS
BEEN ALSO IN SERVICE OF HIS
COMMUNITY AND ALSO WONDERFUL
PERSON THAT- TAUGHT ME SO MUCH
ABOUT LIFE- ALMOST LIKE A
SECOND FATHER TO ME SO I WAS
DEFINITELY THERE BUT I REMEMBER
DURING THE CAMPAIGN SAYING THE
EXCHANGE BETWEEN BOTH OF THEM
THINKING MY BROTHER DOESN'T
HAVEA SHOT AGAINST THIS WOMAN.
AND SHE DID PREVAIL AND OF
COURSE WENT ON TO SERVE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
VERY VERY WELL AND- WE'RE ALL
VERY. PROUD OF HER SERVICES SAN
DIEGO NUMBER IN SUPPORT OF OUR-
ALL THE WORK THAT SHE DID IN
THE COMMUNITY OVER THE YEARS.
AND OF COURSE. AS WE NORMALLY.
GET BEHIND FRIENDS FAMILY AND-
AND WE TEND TO WE TEND TO GET
BEHIND PEOPLE YOU KNOW AS A
FORMER. CHAIRMAN OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS WE ALWAYS WANT TO SEE.
OF A LATINO SKATER A GREATER
SHARE OF- REPRESENTATION OUR
COMMUNITY WE FIGHT FOR THAT I
KNOW THE ASIAN CAUCUS DOES TO
WIN THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WE
ALWAYS A WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET OUR- OUR- THE
PEOPLE FROM OUR COMMUNITY TO
THESE POSITIONS BUT I CAN JUST.
TELL YOU VERY MUCH IT
FRANTICALLY THAT IN THIS IN
THIS CASE HERE I'M I'M VERY-
PROUD TO SEE US COME TOGETHER.
AS A LEGISLATURE. AND RECOGNIZE
THE DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER IS BY
FAR THE BEST PERSON FOR THIS
POSITION IN THE MOST QUALIFIED
POSITION AND LIKE. I FELT BACK
WHEN. MY BROTHER WAS DEFEATED
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT I
KIND OF FELT YOU KOW WHAT I
REALLY IN THE IN THE- IN HE IN
MY HEART BELIEVE. THAT THE
DISTRICT IN THE VOTER SELECTED
THE RIGHT PERSON I THINK WERE
THERE TODAY AGAIN. AND THIS
TIME. I'M ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
THIS DECISION AND- AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING.
WITH DR WEBBER AND I KNOW SAYS
SHE WILL MAKE US ALL PROUD LIKE
SHE HAS. DONE FOR THE LAST OVER
THIRTY YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU AND
PRESIDENT CENTER FOR ALLOWING
ME TO COMMENT ON THE SUIT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBER
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER ATKINS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES
WE DON'T OFTEN GET THE-
OPPORTUNITY- AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY TO TAKE THIS KIND OF
ACTION SO IT IS A SPECIAL DAY.
AND I APPRECIATE THE- I WILL
EARNED WELL DESERVED AND VERY
ACCURATE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE STORIES I
CERTAINLY WISH WE COULD TELL
MANY MORE OF THEM BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT WE ALL HAVE. A
SPECIAL STORIES I DID NOT
RECALL ALL TO MY COLLIE FROM
CITY- THAT EIGHT ON. I WAS AND
I IT'S WHERE I FIRST MET DR
WEBER BUT I. I REALLY DIDN'T
REMEMBER THAT SO I LOVE THE
HISTORY. THE BEST GIFT I HAVE
EVER RECEIVED WAS THE GOSPEL
NIGHT IN THE ASSEMBLY. HEARING
DOCTOR WEBER AND- IS OLSEN'S
VOICES RISE ABOVE THE OTHERS-
IT WAS A VERY SPECIAL GIFT AND
I STILL LISTEN TO IT BECAUSE-
THEY SANG SO WELL- BUT TO CLOSE
I WANT TO PARAPHRASE SOMETHIN-
THAT I SAID YESTERDAY. I
BELIEVE THE STATE BUDGET IS
REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE AS
A BODY. WHEN I WAS SPEAKER AND
NEEDED A BUDGET CHAIR WHO COULD
MATCH THAT AWESOME
RESPONSIBILITY. DR SHIRLEY
WEBER WAS THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THAT JOB. BEING THE STATE'S
CHIEF ELECTIONS OFFICER IS AN
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY AND AS
HAS BEEN TRUE SO MANY TIMES IN
SO MANY SETTINGS DR SHIRLEY
WEBER IS THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THE JOB. SHE'S THE RIGHT PERSON
TO CHAMPION AS SHE SAID
YESTERDAY THE SACRED DEMOCRATIC
ACT OF VOTING. AND WITH THAT I
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE FROM
EACH OF YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. FIVE
BECKER. I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
FIVE CABALLERO I PROTECTING I
DALLY. DODD I TO RAZA HI EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES. LAYERED I LEYVA
I LIMON. MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE ON I Y. CASKEY
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES
VALLEY. GROSS JONES. LIMóN
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN OTOBO. WILK.
FIVE THREE NINE ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. TWENTY NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO ELECTIONS IN THE
CLEARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
CENTER NUMBER. ARE YOU HAPPY
FOR U. S. B. TWENTY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
MAIL A VOTE BY MAIL IN BALLOT
TO EVERY ACTIVE REGISTERED
VOTER FOR SPECIAL ACTIONS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ALSO REQUIRE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
USE VOTE BY MAIL TRACKING
SYSTEM. TO ALLOW VOTERS TO
TRACK THEIR BALLOTS- THIS FALL
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE EXPAND IN
THE NOVEMBER. ONLY TWENTY
ELECTION. AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL IN THE MIDST OF THE
PANDEMIC AND PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF VOTERS AS
WELL AS ELECTION WORKERS IS A
CRITICAL RESPONSIBILITY. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY- WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST TURNOUT WE'VE HAD
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMAN. WAS IN
OFFICE BY THEWAY IS AN ASIDE
WHEN MY STAFF MEMBERS ASKED TO
A VOTED FOR NOT LIKE AND I DID
NOT HOLD NOT ELECTION. THE BE
ALL VOTE IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY TURNOUT WAS OVER 80% IT
IS. ATTENTIVELY SORT OF
POIGNANT THAT WE ARE CONFIRMING
DR WEBER IS SECRETARY OF STATE
TODAY. BECAUSE WE HAD A
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THAT REALLY EXCEEDED
OTHER ELECTIONS DETAILING THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS IS A PERSON
WITH THE KIND OF INTEGRITY. AND
INTELLIGENCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE AN ELECTION AND%
ELECTIONS GOING FORWARD THAT
MEET THAT STANDARD ENACTED
EXCEED THAT STANDARD AND FOR
ALL THESE REASONS ARE TO NOVEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG CENTER
JONES I'M SORRY MEMBERS
DISCUSSION IN ORDER BATES AND-
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS UNFORTUNATELY
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. AND I REALLY WISH I COULD
SUPPORT- BECAUSE I REPRESENT A
RURAL DISTRICT THAT- YOU KNOW
MANY VOTERS IN MY AREA HAVE
BEEN VOTING BY MAIL FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME. BUT THERE USED
TO BE A MEASUREMENT OF SECURITY
IN THE MAIL BALLOT. HE USED TO-
HAVE TO SHOW WHO YOU WERE WHEN
YOU REGISTERED. YOU HAVE TO USE
AFTER THE MAIL THAT IN YOURSELF
WHAT THE SIGNATURE- AFFIRMING
THAT YOU'RE THE VOTER. AND THAT
YOUR AND THAT'S YOUR BALLOT
INSIDE THE ENVELOPE.
UNFORTUNATELY. THERE'S JUST A
LOT OF DEBATE RIGHT NOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REGARDING
THE SECURITY OF OUR MAIL IN
BALLOTS AND I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF ANECDOTAL- YOU KNOW
STORIES FROM AROUND OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY IN OTHER STATES
OF THE COUNTRY AND DEBATE ON
THE- SECURITY OF THOSE MAIL IN
BALLOTS FOR LET ME JUST. SHARE
WITH YOU. PERSONALLY SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT ANECDOTAL. IN THIS
LAST MAIL IN BALLOT IN NOVEMBER.
I HAD TO- CONSTITUENTS THAT I
KNOW PERSONALLY. THAT RECEIVED
THEY VOTED BY MAIL. MAILED IT
IN AND THEN RECEIVED A SECOND
BALLOT BOTH THE HUSBAND AND THE
WIFE. AND THERE'S OTHER
EXAMPLES THEY ARE NOT ANECDOTAL
AND I'LL BET YOU IF ALL OF YOU-
WENT BACK TO YOUR STAFF IN YOUR
DISTRICT OFFICE AND LOOK AT
YOUR LCMS AND- ASKED YOU KNOW
FOR SOME CALLS OR SOME EMAILS.
ON THE BALLOT SECURITY ALL THAT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US HAVE
SOME KIND OF STORY FROM A
CONSTITUENT.THAT HAS SHARED AN
ACTUAL STORY. OF THEIR BALLOT
NOT BEING SECURE. NOW IF WE
COULD SHOW INCALIFORNIA THAT
THE MAIL IN BALLOT IS SECURE I
WOULD. WHOLE AND- I. EXCITEDLY
AS SUPPORT A MAIL IN BALLOT
STATEWIDE. AND MAILED TO
EVERYBODY BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
NOT THERE ON THE BALLOT
SECURITY AND FOR THAT REASON I
WILL BE VOTING NO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SENATOR WIENER. FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TRYING TO
PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE SEEN A
CONCERTED EFFORT AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND I THINK EVERYONE
KNOWS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
AND WHO I'M TALKING ABOUT TO
TRY TO DELEGITIMIZE VOTING IN
THIS COUNTRY TO TRY TO. TO TRY
TO RESTRICT WHO CAN VOTE IT'S
NO LONGER LEGAL TO ACTUALLY
EXPLICITLY BANNING CERTAIN
KINDS OF PEOPLE FROM VOTING THE
WAY THAT WE USED TO IN THIS
COUNTRY BASED ON RACE OR
WHATEVER ELSE SO NOW WE SEE
EFFORTS TO RESTRICT VOTING
THROUGH OTHER MORE NEFARIOUS
WAYS IN SOME SENSE BECAUSE IT
ACCOMPLISHES THE SAME RESULT.
BUT IT'S NOT EXPLICITLY LABELED
BLACK PEOPLE CAN'T VOTE FOR
THIS KIND OF PERSON COUNT VOTER
THAT KIND OF PERSON CAN VOTE
AND WE THEATER EFFORTS AROUND
THE COUNTRY WITH THESE VOTER ID
LAWS WITH- FRANKLY ILLEGAL
PURCHASE OF VOTERS AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WITH OTHER STATES
WE'RE MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE NOT HARDER
AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE
LEARNED FROM THIS LAST
ELECTION. IS THAT THESE
ALLEGATIONS OF VOTER FRAUD
IMPROPRIETIES AND TAKE VOTING
ARE COMPLETELY BOGUS AND WE
LEARNED THAT NOT JUST FROM
DEMOCRATS BUT FROM REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS AND SECRETARIES OF
STATE WHO SAID THE VOTE WAS
TOTALLY APPROPRIATE AND LEGAL
AND NOT. FRAUDULENT SO THIS.
MEASURE TODAY ALLOWS CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE STRONGLY IN
THAT DIRECTION. OF EXTENDING
THE FRANCHISE TO MORE PEOPLE
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
VOTE I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER CENTER
PAN- MADAM PRESIDENT TO
SENATORS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY NINE-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY MY
COUNTY HERE IN SACRAMENTO WAS-
ONE THE PILOT COUNTIES FOR A
VOTE BY MAIL- SEVERAL ACTION
CYCLES AGO AND- IN FACT IT
TURNED OUT VERY SUCCESSFULLY.
AND THERE WAS NO SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF ANY PROBLEMS OR
FRAUD- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AS WE LOOK AT OUR ELECTIONS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR ELECTIONS AND THAT MEANS
THAT IS COMING ON US AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS NOT TO INSINUATES
PROBLEMS UNLESS WE CAN PROVIDE
STRONG EVIDENCE FOR THAT- ARE
PAST SECRETARY OF STATE IS NOW
ARE YOU A CENTER AND OUR FUTURE
SECRETARY OF STATE I'M SURE.
THE GATE- ANY ISSUES THAT
ARISE- AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IF WE ARE AWARE
EACH OF US IS ELECTED
OFFICIALS- ARE AWARE OF
PROBLEMS THEN WE SHOULD. HAVE
THEM IVESTIGATED SO WE CAN
HAVE AN ACTUAL- RULING ON WHAT
THE LEVEL OF TALENT AS IT IS
NOW I WILL POINT OUT THOUGH IS
THAT CERTAINLY THIS HAS BEEN
DONE. AND IN FACT- ARE- MEDIA
PAST PRESENT UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY CONVENED A COMMISSION
AND THEN DISBANDED WINDOWS NO
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT THEY
FOUND- IN ADDITION THERE BEEN
NUMEROUS INVESTIGATIONS DONE OF
ALLEGATIONS HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY BY. ELECTION OFFICIALS
OF BOTH PARTIES. WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY FOUND NO
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS BENDS
ADDITION WE'VE HAD OUR
INDEPENDENT PRESS ALSO TRADED
INVESTIGATIONS AND NOT FOUND
SIGNIFICATIONS SO I HOPE THAT
WE WHO ACTUALLY- ARE IN OUR
POSITIONS BECAUSE OF THE
ELECTION SYSTEM WE HAVE SO WE A
PROBLEM TODAY I GUESS WE SHOULD
QUESTION OUR OWN PRESENCE HERE.
WE SHOULD CERTAINLY HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE BUT ALSO WE SHOULD
BE VERY CAREFUL NOT TO
INSINUATE. SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
WHEN THERE IS WE CANNOT PRESENT
EVIDENCE THAT THEY EXIST AND SO
WITH THAT I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU
CENTER PANTS CENTER BRADFORD.
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWENTY NINE AND- I'M SOMEWHAT
DISMAYED WHEN I HEAR SOME OF
THE BOGUS ARGUMENTS ON WHY.
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO MAIL IN THEIR
BALLOTS BUT IT'S REALLY IRONIC
TO ME THAT. MANY OF THE FOLKS
WHO. ARGUED ABOUT. VOTER
IRREGULARITIES AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN AT THE TOP
OF THE BALLOT. THEY WERE QUITE
FINING BEING SWORN IN
INVALIDATING THEIR ELECTION BE
IT TO CONGRESO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE BUT- EVERYTHING
ELSE AT THE TOP WAS BOGUS SO- I
THINK YOU NEED TO REALLY LOOK
AT YOURSELVES AND I. ASK THE
QUESTION WHO ARE YOU REALLY
TRYING TO- PREVENT FROM VOTING
I THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE
CONCERNS THIS WAS STATED- EVERY
PLACE THAT. THE SELECTION WAS
QUESTION- OUTSIDE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. AND A POOR PEOPLE
AND- IT IN THIS IS WHO THIS IS
TARGETING SAME HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M EXCITED ABOUT
DR WEBER- BECOMING OUR NEW
SECRETARY OF STATE AND I THINK
THE ACCOLADES THAT EVEN THE
FOLKS SPOKE ABOUT DR WEBER'S
INTEGRITY EVEN THOSE WHO DID
NOT VOTE FOR SPEAKS TO WHY THEY
SHOULD. VOTE FOR THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOMEONE NOW WHO
WILL MAKE SURE AND CONTINUE ON
IN A FINE EXAMPLE OF OUR
PREVIOUS SECRETARY OF STATE
MAKE SURE ALL VOTES ARE COUNTED
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REGARDING WHAT YOUR PARTY IS
WHAT YOUR GENDER WHAT'S YOUR
ECONOMIC STATUS SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD MEMBERS SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE-
AMBER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TWENTY FIRST
RESPOND MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO WITH RESPECT TO THE
INTEGRITY OF THE VOTING BY
MAIL. WOULD BE TO GET A VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT YOU HAVE TO BE
REGISTERED YOU HAVE TO SIGN A
SIGNATURE CARD. AND WHEN YOU
VOTE BY MAIL THT SIGNATURES
CHECK ONE IS RETURNED AND IN
FACT NOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
TRACKED THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE. ILLEGALITIES ARE
ABNORMALITIES THEY SHOULD BE
REPORTED. BUT AS OTHERS
SUGGESTED THOSE REPORTS HAVE
BOND. INVESTIGATED BUT FOUND
NOT TO BE PARTICULARLY- THERE
WAS ACTUALLY NO WRONG THERE ARE
FOR THE MOST PART. LET ME
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH SOME OF
THE COMMENTS ABOUT MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES. FOR TWO CENTURIES
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THE
ISSUE OF WHO. MAY AND MAY NOT
VOTE. TO CENTER AGO ONLY MEN
LANDOWNERS OLD TO VOTE ART
TODAY WE'VE EXPANDED GREATLY AS
IS APPROPRIATE. AS IS RIGHT.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS THIS
ENABLES THOSE WHO ARE IN MARIN
COMMUNITIES THOSE WHO MAY NOT
BE WELL THOSE NO CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH THE BILL TO
VOTE. FROM HOME. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. ALL OTHER
POINTS IS IT. WHEN WE CHALLENGE
THE PROCESS AND WE SUGGESTS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT SELECTION WAS
STOLEN YOU ARE HERE OTHER
PLACES WE DO GREAT HARM TO
DEMOCRACY. OUR WORDS HAVE POWER
AND THAT POWER THEN CAN
INFLUENCE OTHERS IF THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS ELECTION WAS
ELECTION HELD WITH INTEGRITY.
AND THEY RESORT TO OTHER MEANS
FAVORS ARE TWO OTHER NAMES TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION SO IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
LISTEN TO PEOPLE LIKE BILL BARR
EVEN MITCH MCCONNELL WHO SAYS
THIS ELECTION. WAS DONE IN A
WAY THAT AMERICANS CAN BE PROUD
OF. WE HAVE TO BE CONFIDENT AND
WE HAVE TO EXPRESS OUR
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM THIS
IS THE GREATEST DEMOCRACY THE
WORLD HAS EVER KNOWN WE CANNOT
UNDERMINE THE TIRED TONIGHT
BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR AMBER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS FIVE BECKER. FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I
PROTESTING HI DOLLY. DODD FIVE
TO RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I HER TADO
I JONES NO LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
THE MON. MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
NO MAN HI NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN.
NO A CHIRLA BOTH. NUMBER NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN. I'M
BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK NOW. THEN
REMOVES THE CALL. MEMBERS WE AT
THIS MOMENT WE DO HAVE SOME
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE
WAITING ON TWO BILLS TO COME
OVER FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO UNTIL
WE GET THOSE BILLS WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A PAUSE PLEASE DO NOT
LEAVE THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECESS UNTIL TEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE BE BACK ON THE
SENATE FLOOR AT TEN THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU. AND IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GO BACK TO YOUR OFFICES
SO WE CAN REMAIN WE CAN REMAIN
SOCIALLY DISTANCED PLEASE
PLEASE LEAVE THE FLOOR AND GO
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE IF
WE CAN ASK EVERYONE TO GET BACK
TO THEIR SEATS SO WE CAN GET
STARTED. MEMBERS WE SHOULD HAVE
A SUPPLEMENTAL FILE IN FRONT OF
YOU. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE ONE
PLEASE LET US KNOW WE WILL GET
YOU ONE. ADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ THE ASSEMBLY
MESSAGE. MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL EIGHTY NINE AND SENATE
BILL NINETY ONE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE
SAID AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE
BILLS ORDER TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY MEMBERS WILL START
WITH FILE ITEM FIVE SB EIGHTY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELT.
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- LET ME GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BACKGROUND BEFORE
PERCENT THIS BE EIGHTY NINE. SO
I THINK WE ARE ALL AWARE THAT
EVEN PRIOR TO THE A PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIA HAD ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ALREADY FACED.
HAVING TO CONTRIBUTE ABOUT 50%
OF THEIR INCOME TOWARDS RENT.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC ACCORDING TO
DATA BY OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE. 53% BOB THE JOB LOSSES
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCED.
PANDEMIC ARE LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THOSE SAME
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ALREADY WELL
THEY HAD JOBS WERE FACING
PUTTING 50% OF THEIR INCOME TO
RENT. WE PASSED THE BILL LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PROVIDED A
FICTION PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE
MONTH. WE NOW KNOW THAT WE
STILL HAVE MANY MANY PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED. AND MANY PEOPLE NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY THEIR FULL
RENT WHICH NOT ONLY IMPACTS
THAT HOUSEHOLD BUT POPULARLY
OBVIOUSLY IMPACTS THE OWNERS OF
THE PROPERTY WHO STILL HAVE
BILLS AND MUST MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS. FORTUNATELY THE
FEDERAL PASSAGE OF THE LATEST
CARES ACT IN DECEMBER PROVIDES
TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE. TO
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THE BILLS
BEFORE US HELP US EXTEND THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE PROVIDED
LAST YEAR AND GREEN LIGHT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR THE BILL YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU RIGHT NOW IS A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR SB EIGHTY
NINE ASSOCIATED WITH BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND IT SETS UP
THESE ITEMS FOR THE PRINTER
FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE THAT
ARE LAID OUT IN THE FOLLOWING
BILL ALL PRESENT SB NINETY ONE.
SERVICE BE EIGHTY NINE IS
TECHNICAL. JUST FACILITY THE
ABILITY FOR US TO DO WHAT IS IN
SB NINETY ONE AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. LETTERPRESS
LED DOWN THE SENATE I WOULD
FIND THIS MEASURE AS WE SAW IT
BEFORE WORTHY OF AN AYE VOTE.
THERE ARE STILL SOME
DEFICIENCIES IN IT I THINK I
BELIEVE THAT THE ASSURANCES TO
LANDLORDS ARE NOT SUFFICIENT
AND THAT THEY CAN YET BE SORT
CHANGED. I REALIZE THAT THIS IS
A BILL THAT DOES NEED TO BE
EXPEDITED AND THEREFORE I
SUPPORT THE MEASURE TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN.
CENTER GROVE DID- NOPE DID I
SEE YOUR HEAD UP I DID NOT ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING. CENTER
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU YES I DID NOT MENTION
THAT THIS BILL WAS HEARD AS WHO
IS THE ONE I WILL PRESENT
FOLLOWING BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON TUESDAY. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BACKER I FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO HI
PROTESTING I DALY FIVE DODD. I
TO RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH I
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES I LAYERED. I LEYVA
AYE LIMóN. MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
I A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN HI
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER I STERN. AMBERG HI
WE CASKEY I WIENER. I WILK HI
SEN REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING O THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR SKINNER MANAGE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINETY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEWAND ACTUALLY NEED TO
TENDENCY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SANDERS CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
OUR STAFF AND THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. WHO SPENT A GOOD
DEAL OF HOURS. NEGOTIATING WHAT
WE JUST VOTED ON AND WHAT I AM
PRESENTING RIGHT NOW. TO
PROVIDE THE ASSISTANCE THAT WE
KNOW SO MANY OF OUR RENTERS AND
THEY'RE LANDLORDS THEIR
PROPERTY OWNERS NEED RIGHT NOW.
SB NINETY ONE. IS THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND- EVICTION
PROTECTION BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
IT SUPPORTS RENTERS AND OWNERS
WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY COVE
IT. AND IT BALANCES THE NEEDS
OF THOSE TENANTS WHO ARE NOT
CURRENTLY BEING ABLE TO MEET
THEIR RENT WITH INCENTIVES FOR
LANDLORDS COOPERATION BUT ALSO
ENSURE THAT THOSE LANDLORDS
THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS TO
RECEIVE. A GOOD PORTION OF THE
BACK RENT. THE BILL EXTENDS THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM AND OTHER
RENTAL OF PROTECTIONS
ESTABLISHED IN AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT SETS UP THE
STATE'S RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WITH THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WERE APPROPRIATED ENACTED
CIMBER CARES ACT. IT ALLOCATES
THE FUNDING TO LOCALITIES BY
POPULATION INCLUDING A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION TO SMALL AND
RURAL COUNTIES. THERE IS
ADDITIONALLY FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL MONIES THAT GO DIRECTLY
TO MANY OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND IT WILL BE
MANAGED EITHER LOCALLY OR BY A
CONTRACTED STATEWIDE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTER. AND IT PROVIDES
FOR THOSE LANDLORDS WHO CHOOSE
TO PARTICIPATE 80% OF THE BACK
RENT THAT THEIR TENANTS- AND
THE REST IS FORGIVEN. AND IT
PROVIDES 25% IF THE LANDLORDS
DO NOT PARTICIPATE BUT IT DOES
ENSURE THAT AT LEAST THERE IS A
FICTION PROTECTIONS. AND IT
INCLUDES LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR
RENTERS TO ENCOURAGE LANDLORDS
TO PARTICIPATE. AND WITH THAT
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR ATKINS. YOU SO
MUCH HI COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE
WHICH WOULD EXTEND THE
EVICTIONS MORATORIUM AND HELP
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS. CLEARLY ONE OF OUR
MOST URGENT AND CRITICAL NEEDS
RIGHT NOW. REMENT REACHED
EARLIER THIS WEEK WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM WHICH
RELIES ON A FRAMEWORK DEVELOPED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
MAKES CALIFORNIA'S MORATORIUM
AND THE STRONGEST OF ITS KIND
IN THE COUNTRY. AND THAT SPELL
STABILITY FOR TENANTS AND SMALL
LANDLORDS. AS THE BUDGET CHAIR
SAID IT STRIKES A BALANCE OF
STABILIZING RENT PAYMENTS WHILE
EXTENDING THE SAME KIND OF DO
NO HARM PROTECTIONS. FOR
TENANTS THAT WE ENACTED UNDER
AB THIRTY THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL COVERT NINETEEN
TENANT PROTECTIONS AGAINST
UNFORGIVING CREDITORS AND BAD
ACTING LANDLORDS. IT ALSO HELPS
SMALL LANDLORDS WHO RELY ON
RENT AS BASIC INCOME AND ARE ON
THE BRINK OF LOSING THEIR
PROPERTIES TO FORECLOSURE. THIS
IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS NOT
THE END. I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THIS WILL WORK AND CONCERNS
ABOUT THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL
WILL HELP REAL CALIFORNIANS. SO
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
SAY THAT IT WILL. AND PART OF
OUR WORK OVER THESE NEXT DAYS
AND WEEKS HAS TO BE TO HELP OUR
CONSTITUENTS UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS EXTENSION WILL PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THOSE IN NEED. THAT'S
OUR CHARGE. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS IN THE MONTHS
AHEAD WHICH INCLUDES OVERSEEING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
PROGRAM. AND PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO WHAT IS WORKING
AND WHAT IS NOT WORKING. SO WE
CAN GARNER ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE OR FLEXIBILITY FROM
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. IN ORDER
TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED. AS
CALIFORNIANS WE FIND OURSELF IN
THAT PERFECT STORM. LITERALLY
TODAY AND FIGURATIVELY A
PANDEMIC. RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT
AND A HOUSING CRISIS. AS LONG
OAK MAKERS WE FND OURSELVES IN
THE MOMENT THAT REQUIRES
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP. FOCUS
AND IN THE WORDS OF OUR- PRIOR
PRO TEN. INTENTIONALITY I THINK
THAT WORD APPLIES HERE TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES PARTICULARLY ARE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER THE
SENATORS FROM SALINAS GUARDINO
BERKELEY AND SANTA ANA FOR
THEIR INITIATIVE AND SKILL IN
GUIDING THESE TALKS. WE ARE
PAINFULLY AWARE OF THE PLIGHT
THAT CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
FACING AS THEY STRUGGLE TO PAY
THE RENT. OR MORTGAGES AT NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN BECAUSE OF
THE PIN PAD TO MAKE THAT WE ARE
IN. IT'S A BURDEN FAR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE CARRYING
TODAY. AS THEY FIGHT TO KEEP
THEIR HOUSING THEIR LIVELIHOODS
AND THEIR HEALTH. SO TODAY WE
HELP CALIFORNIANS KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD AND KEEP THEIR
HEADS ABOVE WATER. COLLEAGUES I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS. SENATOR CORTESE.
OKAY COMMITTEE PRESIDENT OF A-
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE-
AND I WANT TO TAKE OUR OWN
LEADERSHIP FOR. THE SIGNIFICANT
ROLE IN IN BRINGING THIS TO
BEAR IN A TIMELY MANNER. THAT
SAID THERE WAS A ROBUST
DISCUSSION- AT THE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE JUST.
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND I WANNA
MAKE SURE TO MEMORIALIZE- AT
LEAST A COUPLE OF THE POINTS.
THAT ARE RAISED DURING THAT
DISCUSSION- AND BY ASSOCIATION
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MANY SIMILAR
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BUT I
THINK IF THERE WERE A SLOGAN
THAT WE WERE PUTTING TOGETHER
AS WE MOVE THIS EFFORT OF A TO
THE RANK AND FILE RESIDENTS- IT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
WOULD BE AVOID THE OVERWHELM.
IN ONE OF MY CONCERNS. AGAIN
WHICH WAS RAISED. ON WEDNESDAY.
IS THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE-
AND ALLOW ME SAY
PARENTHETICALLY OBVIOUSLY I'M
NOT SUGGESTING AN AMENDMENT.
BUT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE SAYS.
WELL THAT THE P. THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES A PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
CENTRAL TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
APPLICATION PORTAL IN SYSTEM
THE SERVICE LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS. HAS MOBILE AND MULTI
LANGUAGE CAPABILITIES THAT
ALLOWS AN APPLICANT TO TRACK
THE STATUS OF THEIR
APPLICATION. AND REQUIRES THE
APPLICATION SYSTEM TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO HANDLE THE VOLUME
OF EXPORTS EXPECTED. USE
WITHOUT DISRUPTION- THE
QUESTION WAS A- THAT COMMITTEE
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THAT
SYSTEM WOULD INCLUDE A CALL
CENTER- WELL WE LOOK AT THE
OVERALL. A BUDGET EFFORT IN THE
EARLY ACTIONS SO THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO US A BEYOND- THE
MEASURES TODAY THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE- IN THE EQUITY CONCERNS
AROUND THAT HAVE BEEN. AN
ONGOING CONCERN I WANT TO
THANK. THE CHAIR- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BERKELEY THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE FOR. IGNORE TO MY
COMMENTS ON WEDNESDAY IN
MEMORIALIZING GOT TWENTY. AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT. FOR ME I
FEEL TODAY I TO GET ON THE
RECORD AT LEAST A MESSAGE IN
PUBLIC BUT TO THOSE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING THE SYSTEM- IN
TERMS OF OUR OWN
ADMINISTRATION. ARE THAT IT'S
CRITICAL. THAT THE PEOPLE IN
OUR DISTRICTS WERE GOING TO BE.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN- CURIOUS TOO
CONFUSED OR TOO NEEDY WITH
REGARD TO THIS PROGRAM I HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TALK TO SOMEBODY
CULTURALLY COMPETENT. SOMEBODY
WHO CAN GIVE THEM ANSWERS THE
SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT A BOT BUT
SOMEBODY WHO'S A REAL HUMAN
BEING. AND THAT SOMEBODY I
DON'T BELIEVE CAN BE PROVIDED.
BY THIS LEGISLATURE. THROUGH
ITS OWN. I THINK WE'VE KNOWN
THAT WE TRY TO IN THE INTEREST
PAST- AND WHAT WE GET IS
OVERWHELMED. SO WITH THOSE
COMMENTS I DO WANNA. IF WE JUST.
HI THE MY OFF OF THIS CAN TO
SUGGEST THAT IN ADDITION TO OF
LEGAL ASSISTANCE WHICH- THE
FINANCE DEPARTMENT INDICATES OF
WILL BE AVAILABLE PROVIDED
THROUGH PREVIOUS GENERAL FUND-
MEASURES- THE ACTUAL. THE
LANDLORD TENANT MEDIATION
SERVICES BE PART OF WHATEVER
ROLE WHATEVER- THE THAT BECOMES
PART OF THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTERS ROLE- WITH THIS
MEASURE WITH THAT. ARAMBULA
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO GET THOSE
COMMENTS ON THE RECORD IN IN IN
IN ESSENCE BRING THEM FORWARD
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE. THIRTY
CABALLERO. FIFTY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINETY ONE FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE PRO
TEM AND MAJORITY LEADER FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP.
AND THE ROLES THAT THEY PLAYED
IN HELPING TO BRING THIS-
AGREEMENT TOGETHER AS WELL AS
THEIR STAFFS WHO WORKED. THINGS
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH MANY OF
US AT ALL HOURS OF THE DAY AND
WEEK WEEKEND AS WELL IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED SECOND- I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
PARTICULARLY THE MAJORITY
LEADER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING TO
GET THIS DONE. ON TIME SO THAT
WE CAN GET A SIGNATURE FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE- COMMUNICATING TO ALL
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT RENT. THAT THIS
MORATORIUM HAS BEEN EXTENDED.
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING UNDER GREAT
FEAR FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND TO BE ABLE TO TELL
THEM THAT THEY WERE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS IS
REALLY AN- IMPORTANT. AND
FINALLY I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE- SENATOR FROM
GUARDINO AND HIS STAFF FOR
JOINING ME IN THIS EFFORT.
SINCE EARLY LAST YEAR WHEN WE
HAD THE ORIGINAL SENATE BILL TO
INSURE THAT CAL. FOR YOUR
FAMILIES ARE MADE HOUSE DURING
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
EVERYBODY HERE KNOWS TODAY WITH
THE PANDEMIC HAS DONE TO OUR-
TO OUR RESIDENTS IN IN IN OUR
DISTRICTS WE'VE RECEIVED PHONE
CALLS WE'VE TALKED WITH PEOPLE
WE'VE HAD- ZOOM MEETINGS WITH
THEM AND- THE IMPACTS HAVEN'T
REALLY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. OUR PEOPLE WHO ARE
WHO. HAVE BEEN LAID OFF WHO
HAVE HAD THEIR HOURS SLASHED
AND WHO HAVE THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN HAVE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN ECONOMIC DISARRAY
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
ANY MONEY. OTHER THAN
GOVERNMENT LARGESSE TO BE ABLE
TO PAY THEIR BILLS AND THE
REASON IS THAT THIS IS.
TREMENDOUSLY IMPACTED MY
COMMUNITY THE FARMWORKERS. IS
THAT WHEN YOU GET SICK. THERE'S
NO REPLACEMENT WAGES WHEN YOU
GET SICK YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO- EARN A LIVING AND
YOUR FAMILY AND EVERYBODY IN
YOUR HOUSEHOLD SUFFERS. AS
EARLY AS ONE MONTH AFTER THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND ENACTED TO STAY
AT HOME ORDER I LIKE MANY OF
YOU BEGAN HEARING FROM OUR
RESIDENTS. THAT THEY WERE
FALLING BEHIND ON THE RENT AND
THEY HAD LOST BECAUSE THEY HAD
LOST THEIR JOB. AND AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL RECALL THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL STEPPED IN AND
THEY BLOCKED ANY EVICTION AND
DECLARED A MORATORIUM AND
THAT'S- THAT WAS TREMENDOUSLY.
THAT REALLY GAVE US THE THAT WE
NEEDED TO ABLE TO ACT. AND WE
DO WE PASS AB. EIGHTY EIGHT THE-
ASSISTANCE OUR- OF THAT. AND
THE SENATE AND A SINGLE FROM
THE GOVERNOR WE KNEW IT OUR
WORK WAS FAR FOR OVER. A TO
DATA FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA HAS LOST
NEARLY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
JOBS SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. CAN EMPLOYMENT RATE
EXCEEDED SIXTEEN PERCENT. WHICH
IS HIGHER THAN ANY POINT DURING
THE RECESSION AND IN MY
DISTRICT IT'S BEEN DOUBLE DIGIT
UNEMPLOYMENT THE ENTIRE TIME
AND CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. EVD
HAS PROCESSED OVER EIGHTEEN
MILLION CLAIMS BIRD NUMEROUS
EMPLOYEE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. AND SO- ON THE BOTTOM
LINE IN ALL OF THIS IS THAT IS
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED. AND WHILE THE EXACT
FIGURE OF WHAT PAST DUE RENT
WHAT THE AMOUNT OF PAST DUE
RENT. VACILLATE FROM FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION TO FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A
DEBT. THAT IS LOOMING AND IT IS
GOING AND ACCORDING TO THE- ONE
OF THE LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH. THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF THE PAST DUE RENT
IN THEIR REGION IS THAT WITHOUT
SOME ECONOMIC RELIEF TENANTS
WILL BE BURDENED BY RENTAL
RENTAL DEBT. FOR THEIR
LIFETIME. I MEAN THINK ABOUT
THAT FOR THEIR LIFETIME. THEY
WILL NEVER EVER BE ABLE TO PAY.
PAST RENT DO BECAUSE I'LL
ALWAYS BE WORRIED ABOUT PAYING
TO KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
RIGHT NOW UNLESS WE DO
SOMETHING. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM. WITH THE RELIEF
THAT THEY NEED NEED. SO THAT'S
WHY NEED WE NEED TO ACT NOW TO
TURKEY FOR NOW RELIEF. WHEN WE
BE TO RIVAS. AB THIRTY EIGHT
AND HOW TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL RESOURCES WE HAD THREE
MAIN GOALS. IN ORDER TO CREATE
CERTAINTY IN THE HOUSING MARKET
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT IS. TRYING TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THE HOME IN THE HOMES
THAT THEY'RE RENTING AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST IT WAS TO EXTEND THE
MORATORIUM. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES ARE PROTECTED
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. THERE IS NO REATER
PRIORITY SECOND WE WANTED TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
LANDLORDS SMALL LANDLORDS WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO COLLECT
RENT FROM THEIR TENANTS AND ARE
AT RISK OF FORECLOSURE. OR
THEIR ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE THEY
REQUIRE THAT INCOME IN ORDER TO
PAY THEIR BY THEIR OWN BILLS
AND TO MAINTAIN THEIR FAMILY
NEEDS AS WELL. SO AS WE WERE
LOOKING AT THE SITUATION WE
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT TENANTS
WERE DROWNING IN DEBT COULD GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET SO THAT THEY
COULD. THEY WOULDN'T BE SETTLED
BY THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN.
RENTAL DEBT AND FINALLY. ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US WAS TO. PROVIDE
SOME FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE LEGAL AGE THAT I'VE BEEN.
ASSUMING THE BURDEN OF
INFORMING. TENANTS OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND TRYING TO PROTECT
THEM FROM ILLEGAL EVICTIONS.
THAT ARE HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
STATE AND SO THE ADMINISTRATION
AGREED TO EXPEDITE. THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT WE
ALREADY PUT IN THE BUDGET. LAST
YEAR THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. BOB FOR LEGAL AID
OFFICES WERE STRUGGLING TO HELP
TENANTS AND THAT WILL BE
EXPEDITED AS PART OF THIS.
PROCESS IS NOT IN THIS BILL BUT
IT IS IN AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO ACCOMPLISH THESE
GOALS AND I BELIEVE THE MEASURE
BEFORE US PROVIDES IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA TO
NEED MOST. SO THAT WE CAN SEE A
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
EVERY DAY MORE CALIFORNIANS ARE
RECEIVING THE VACCINE AND ONE
OF THESE DAYS ARE GOING TO HAVE
THIS BEHIND US. BUT WE'RE NOT
DONE YET. SO IN THE MEANTIME
THIS SENATOR FROM GUARDIAN AND
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WE HAVE THE BILL SB THREE
THAT- WE WILL MOVE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
DEALT WITH- IT IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- AND TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS REALLY IS
A COMPROMISE IS NOT A PERFECT
BILL IT'S A COMPROMISE. AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE TENANT
AND THE LANDLORD TO BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH WITH MY OFFICE I
KNOW I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
YEARS WITHOUT YOUR INPUT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO REACH THIS
COMPROMISED. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE TODAY ON
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT BILL SO
THAT WE CAN ASSURE CALIFORNIANS
THAT THEY CAN STAY IN THE HOUSE
IN THEIR HOUSE OR APARTMENT
THAT THEY'RE RENTING. AND THAT
WE HAVE SOME FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE ON THE WAY TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
PAY TO HELP PAY DOWN SOME OF
THE DEBT AND HELP SOME OF OUR
SMALL AND LARGE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CABALLERO SENATOR.
THANK YOU MA'AM. I RISE- CALL.
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS MEASURE. AND
LAST AUGUST WE WERE OUT TO- PUT-
AND- I BELIEVE THAT WAS THE
THING TO DO WITH THE COPIER
THAT WE WOULD NOT- IN THIS
MONTH UNLESS THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED TO LANDLORDS. BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T FIX A PROBLEM IF
YOU'RE ONLY ADDRESSING HALF OF
IT I STILL FEEL THAT WAY TODAY.
THIS FEDERAL FUNDING SOURCE
IT'S A LITTLE CONFUSING. BUT
FIRST AND FOREMOST ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION. THAT'S A JOKE.
NOW IT'S A GOOD START BUT
ULTIMATELY WE'RE GOING TO NEED
MUCH MORE AND I DON'T KNOW THE
FULL BREADTH OF- MY COLLEAGUES
BILL SB THREE- AND WHAT THAT
WILL PROVIDE FOR LANDLORDS. BUT
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HONOR- THE INTERESTS AND- THE
HOPE THAT WE HAVE GIVEN TO- NOT
ONLY THE TENANTS BUT ALSO
LANDLORDS CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO
STEP UP. IN COMPLEMENT THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING. SO ALL THESE
FRESNO IS THE AS A QUICK
EXAMPLE APPARENTLY- IN PHASE
ONE OF THIS PROGRAM. AND THE
MEDIAN INCOME IN FRESNO IS
FIFTY THOUSAND. THAT MEANS
HOUSEHOLDS EARNING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM WE'RE BY THE
LANDLORD RETROACTIVELY IS ABLE
TO- ACCUMULATE- IN SATISFIED
PASS DEBTS FOR THE YEAR- BUT WE
KNOW THAT IS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
RENTING. FOR THOSE HOUSEHOLDS
OR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. I THAT
I THINK A OF SOME THE SAID
ISRAEL TWO WHERE YOU OF
COMMUNITIES. AFFECTED BY COBIT
AS TO TURN BY THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS I KNOW THAT IT
WILL FIND ITS WAY OUT IN
THROUGH ITS SYSTEM. BUT I THINK
WE NEED A BIT MORE CLARITY ON
WHAT DISCRETION IN METRICS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO USE IN ROUND
TWO. AND FINALLY IN ROUND THREE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT COVERED BY IN
ROUND ONE OR TWO WITH INCOMES
LESS THAN. EIGHTY PERCENT. SO
WHAT I'M SAYING WITH ALL OF
THIS IS I'M NOT EXCITED ABOUT
SUPPORTING THIS ONLY BECAUSE-
IT IS SO LIMITED BUT I WILL
SUPPORT IT AND I'M AND VERY
HOPEFUL. IN FACT I BE PLEADING
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TODAY. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT BILLS ARE IN
THE WORKS RIGHT NOW OR OR
ADVANCING- SERIOUSLY. BUT I
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
STEP UP AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
NOT ONLY TO THE TENANTS WHICH
WERE DOING. BUT ALSO THE
LANDLORDS BECAUSE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION GIVEN THE NEEDS
THAT WE BUT HER PROXIMITY-
ANYWHERE FROM FOUR FIVE BILLION
OR EVEN MORE. THAT THIS WON'T
BE ENOUGH IF WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT MAKING MAKING CERTAIN
THAT OUR HOUSING STOCK AND
HOUSING MARKETS. STABILIZE IN
RECOVERS ACTIVELY SO WITH THAT
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS ITEM
TODAY BUT WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THERE WILL BE A CALIFORNIA
COMPANION BILL TO SUPPLEMENT ON
THIS- VERY FUNDING SOURCE.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM ARRIVED IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR NINETY.
HUNDRED THAT THERE ARE- OURS
NEEDS WE'RE GONNA NEED TO CAN
TO MINE AND A MONTH- TO MAKE
SURE. THAT ALL OF ALL OF OUR
RENTERS ARE PRETTY AND ABLE TO
THE RIGHT THAT CLEARED- WE KNOW
THAT WE THREE PENDING. BECAUSE
THIS KIND IN THE AREA MASSIVE
SIX INCREASING HOMELESS- AND
HOW AND SO- NUMBER TWO. RENTER
AKEEM MASSIVE MASS RENT THAT SO
RENTED THAT THEY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO CLEAR AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC IS OVER AND NUMBER
THREE- SMALL LAMB GOING IN THE
MASS FOR CLOSE- FOR NOT GET THE
AND THAT THEY- THIS BILL- IT-
ADDRESS ALL TO OF THOSE ISSUES
IT KEEPS PEOPLE TABLE BY FELL.
IT'S IT WILL ALLOW- MANY
TENANTS TO CLEAR THEIR RENT
THAT AND IT WILL ALLOW MANY
WELL KNOWN- TO GET THE INCOME
THAT THEY NEED AND NOT GO INTO
FORECLOSURE- I DO WANT TO
TESTING KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR ARM
MANY PEOPLE IN THE RENTER
COMMUNITY. WHO DO OF THAT I
SHARE THAT. RENTERS NOT BE ABLE
TO THE ACCESS- THE BULK OF
THESE FOR THAT HAS TO BE BOB.
PROTESTS BY LANDLORD- AND
ALTHOUGH I THINK THERE ARE SO
AND SO. FOR LANDLORDS TO. IS
FINE. ARE HI I'M CAN THERE ARE
SOME. WHO WON. BENEFIT FROM THE
CLEARING OF THE ROAD THAT DIE
AS A CAN. TO ME AND OTHERS- BUT
I THINK THAT WE NEED WATCH THE
AMPLE. OF THIS VERY VERY CARE I
MAY US. AS NEEDED- ON STRONG
BALANCE IS THE TO AND WILL
PROTECT A LOT OF. AN I ASK FOR
A AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATE
WIENER SAID RUBIO. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND OF THE
OTHER SENATE TODAY I RISE. TO
PER OF ALL THANK OUR- AND ALL
THOSE INVOLVED IN NEW. AND MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FOR PRESENTING
THIS IN MATTER. THIS IS A STEP
TO PROVIDING. FOR WORSE. TO
KEEP THEIR HOME. OUR COMMUNITY
ARE EXPECT ALL OF US TO COME.
AND STOP THE WAY THE THICK.
THIS BILL TAKES ABOUT OF. TO
ASSIST TEN WITH PETS TO READ.
AS WELL AS- WHO'VE BEEN A IN
FAITH. I'M THAT ALL OF US CAME
TOGETHER THIS. YES AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REACH THE
SUPREME. AND THAT AT ALL
INCLUDES LEGALLY WHICH IS VITAL
TO ALL OF CAN. BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANT PROVIDING RELIEF. IT
IS EQUALLY AND THAT WE A SIXTY
PLAN. TO DECEMBER AND GET
PEOPLE THE GUY SAYING. S. THE
BOTTOM STATED THAT STEP IS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS PRO WORKS. R.
O. ARE- X. FRUSTRATE. OVER THE
GLITTER OF OTHER. AND ASSIST
FROM SAN CLARA STE- AS LEAD. WE
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE SUPPORT WE
PROVIDE IS TO. CULTURALLY SO.
AND MULTI. AND SHOULD ALSO IN
OKAY CENTER. SO THE OF FOR WE
SIX. TO ALL THOSE THAT DON'T
HAVE TAKEN A OR I. TO I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE DOES. AND SUPPORT FOR
BUSINESS AND RUN SPACE KOMMER
EFFECTS. I HEARD TOO MANY
STORIES OF MOM AND POP. READY
TO GO BECAUSE THEY CANNOT TO
RUN AND ARE GETTING READY TO BE
AFFECT. TELL ME THAT'S ON. INTO
LAST AND CAL. I LOOK FOR TAKEN.
TO SUPPORT WORK AND I URGE AND
I THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AS I RIDE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MAY. I SO.
TAKING MOMENT TO READ THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH WE FIND OUR I
STAND HERE BUT PARKS. SOCIALLY
THROUGH THE CDC GUARD. NOT
ALLOWED ON FLOOR UNTIL WE'RE-
THIS IS TURN THIS UP SO DOWN IN
EVERY WAY. AND PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO HELP. WE HAVE A
SERIES OF ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
OPENING THE SCHOOLS AND GETTING
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL OR GETTING
BUSINESSES OPEN AND DEALING
WITH ALL THE ECONOMIC DOWN
TURNS THIS IS ONE OF MANY MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE FACE. WE
ARE FORTUNATE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE AND AS THIS IS
WRITTEN UNDER THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE PUT TOGETHER
TO OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS. TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
THE FRAMEWORK. EMBODIED HERE X.
IS THE FRAMEWORK LARGELY
CREATED LAST YEAR'S RESULT OF
EXTRAORDINARY NEGOTIATIONS
AMONG ALL THE PARTIES PUTTING A
LOT OF ELBOW GREASE INTO IT.
THE QUESTION IS AS WAS
MENTIONED WHAT'S THE SIZE OF
THE DEBT NOBODY KNOWS. BUT THE
ISSUE THAT WE FACE HERE JUST
VERY BRIEFLY IS INACTION.
INACTION MEANS THAT ON SUNDAY I
THINK IT IS THE THIRTY FIRST IF
THAT'S THE DATE THIS MORATORIUM
GOES AWAY AS WRITTEN. IN OUR AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WE'VE GOT
TO EXTEND IT SO PEOPLE AREN'T
THROWN OUT WE'VE GOT TO EXTEND
IT SO THAT THE DEBT THE PEOPLE
WERE TALKED ABOUT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. THAT THE BALLOON
PAYMENTS THAT WERE DUE ON THE
THIRTY FIRST AND THAT HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED. AND YOU KNOW IF WE
LOOK AT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SAYS THAT THE
HISTORY THAT THE RIVER JUST AS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
PLENTY OF MONEY. EVEN IF IT'S
LARGER NO ONE KNOWS AND SO AS
FOLKS ARE LOOKING AT THIS AND
SAYING WELL IT'S NOT PERFECT
WHAT I SAY IS THAT NUMBER ONE
WE HAVE TO ACT AND WE HAVE TO
ACT NOW WE HAVE A LOT MORE
RESPONSIBILITY IS THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION MOVES
FORWARD TO ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLKS IN. CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH SO MANY OF THE
CHALLENGING NEEDS AND THIS PUTS
A LOT OF MONEY ON THE TABLE
FOR. PROPERTY OWNERS WHO MAY BE
LOSING THEIR PROPERTIES A SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS ELIMINATES
UNTIL AUGUST FIRST THE ABILITY
OF ANY LANDLORD EVEN IF THEY
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE IN A
PROCEEDING- AGAINST SOMEBODY
WHO ALWAYS A REAR EDGES AND
RUNS. AT IS THIS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEBATES WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS THERE'S
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
RELIEF PERSON BY PERSON AS A
RESULT OF THIS DOLLARS THAT ARE
BEING AFFORDED TODAY. WAS A LOT
OF DETAILS IN IT I WANT TO
THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER IN
THE OTHER HOUSE FOR HER
INVOLVEMENT IN HELPING CONVENE
A WHOLE HOST OF FOLKS AT THE
DIRECTION THE SPEAKER IN THE
PROGRAM. AND ACID. YOU WILL IN
FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CENTER HER.
SENATOR- OTOBO. VERY GOOD WILL
MOVE ON THIS NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM THAT I'D FIVE ONE
TO. BE CLEAR I APPRECIATE THE
REMARKS OF THE LEADER DEGREE
ABOUT THE CON IN WHICH WE MAKE
THIS. I WANT TO BUILD A LITTLE
BIT OF THE COME OF MY CALL FROM
SAN I CAN I WILL BE SERV THE
BILL TODAY- BUT I CONTINUE TO
HAVE CAN ABOUT APPARENT IN THE
QUEUE IN THE OF THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY THE SECTION REGARD
REIMBURSE OF LAND FOR TO. WHO
QUALIFY FOR A IT'S REALLY. AS
I'M IN THE RECENT BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON THIS TO THERE TO
BE SICK LEVEL OF CAN. AROUND
THE TERM OF THE REAR PAYMENT
FOR. THE RALLY TEXT OF THE BILL
READ QUOTE PROCESS FOR RENT
ARREARS LYNNE TO COP OF EIGHTY
PER. OF AN ELEGY HOUSEHOLD ON
PAID RENTAL DE CAME FROM APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TO THIRTY TWENTY
TWENTY IN. PER ELIGIBLE HOUSE
YEAH IN RESPONSE MY QUESTION
INCOME WE WERE TO BY MANY FOR.
THAT THE INTO OF THE IS TO
FULLY REIMBURSE 80% SURE OF THE
ARENA RIDGE ROAD HOWEVER IS
MEMORIAL THE RELEVANT LANGUAGE
NOT X. PROVIDE THAT ASSURE. TO
LANDLORDS NOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SHALL BE LIMITED TO AND
SHALL BE THE IS FAR MORE THAN
SEMANTIC IN THISCASE MANY
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
JUSTIFIABLY CONCERNED THAT
GIVEN THIS LANGUAGE AS WELL AS
PAST EXPERIENCE WITH SIMILAR
PROGRAMS THAT THEY MAY ENTER
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH AFFECTED
TENANTS. ONLY TO FIND OUT LATER
THAT THE ORIGINAL PERSON THEY
RECEIVE WILL BE FAR LESS THAN
THAT 80% WHICH IS THE UPPER
LIMIT SPECIFIED IN THE
LEGISLATION THE MOMENT NOW THAT
PERSISTENCE OF THAT AMBIGUITY
IS NO SMALL THING. IT'S GOING
TO HAVE A MATERIAL IMPACT ON
THE WILLINGNESS OF LANDLORDS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE TOTAL
AMOUNT NEEDED VERSUS THE TOTAL
AMOUNT WILL HAVE AVAILABLE NOW
THAT HESITANCY OR WORSE A
DECISION NOT TO PARTICIPATE
COULD POTENTIALLY DELAY OR
PREVENT RELIEF TO TENANTS. WHO
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND NEEDED
NOW THE RELEASE IS ALSO. TO A
LARGE NUMBER OF LAND. MANY OF
WHOM ARE FOR FROM WEALTH. AND
FIND ON INTENSE. AS WELL TO ME
THE ROBERT. ON MORTGAGE. WELL
ADEQUATELY. THE PROPERTY THEY
RENT AND MANAGE AS THE PRO TO
MENTION THE WORK WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGHT THE DETAILS ON THIS
REPORT LEGISLATION. I WOULD ASK
THAT THIS AMBIGUITY BE
ADDRESSED IN THAT PROCESS BUT
IN THE INTERIM I RICHARD AND I
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER NEW. SENATOR
OKAY. THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
COMING TO ME. NOT IMPRESSED AND
MEMBERS THANK FOR THEIR PART TO
SPEAK AYE FOR TAKING TIME TO
REVIEW BILL GOING TO SAY THE
MEASURE. APRIL SHE DID THE AND
ROBUST IN BUDGET CAN THIS WEEK
AND HOPE THAT DISCUSS CAN INTO
THE WEEKS. I HAVE ABOUT HOW
THIS BILL WILL BE. WE NEED
STRONG GUARANTEE THAT THESE
THIS MY- THAT THIS MONEY GET
OUT INTO OUR COMMUNITY. I ASK
THIS BODY WORKING TO FOR THIS
TO UPON THAT WILL TRULY AND THE-
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS. TO BE
PROACTIVE IN THIS IS AND THE
WORK THAT'S MONTHS A- I HOPE
THAT WE CONTINUE WORK TO POLICY
AND JUST OUR- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OCTOBER. CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HIGH
USE IN SOME. OF AS FOR NOT ONE
AND I WANT TO THANK MY CO. THAT
I WORK RIGHT FROM- IN BEING- TO
LEAD OFF. ON IT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY LAST YEAR AND AS ALL. OF
STATE THIS IS NOT A PER PIECE
WHAT. BUT IT'S A NEED PIECE OF
BLOOD. SPECIAL ANY STAR. IT'S A
PIECE OF WHAT. THAT PROTECTS.
NOT JUST A- BUT THE LAN. AS
WELL AND I WAS COULD AND TO ME.
BECAUSE MANY TIMES WE CONFUSE
AND THINK THAT IF YOUR LANDLORD
YOUR SOME WEALTHY INDIVIDUAL.
BUT MNY OF THESE LANDLORDS ARE
TEACHERS THERE ARE BUS DRIVERS
THERE ARE MAIL CARRIERS. THERE
ARE POLICE OFFICERS. AND SOME
ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND THE
JUSTICE MONDAY AS I PREPARING
TO BE A PLANE AT ALL. I WAS
APPROACHED BY ONE OF THESE
POLICE OFFICERS. WHO HAPPENS
OWN RENTAL PROPERTY. ANY STATED
SOME OF HIS CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO. S. B. AB THIRTY
EIGHTY BUT HE ALSO WAS GRATEFUL
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. BUT HE
ALSO EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT
DESPITE THE REQUIREMENT OF
SHOWING A GOOD FAITH EFFORT OF
MAKING AT LEAST 25% OF THE RED
SEA SOME OF HIS TENANTS HAD
FAILED TO DO SO. N. AS HE
STATED THE LAST THING THAT MANY
OF THESE MOM AND POP OPERATORS
WANT TO DO IS EVICT SOMEONE
FROM THEIR APARTMENT MANY OF
THESE FOLKS VIEW THESE PEOPLE
AS FAMILY. MANY HAVE BEEN IN
THEIR BUILDING FOR DECADES AND
SO THAT'S THE LAST THING THEY
WANT TO DO SO THIS HELPS THE
SMALL LANDLORDS AS WELL AS
TENANTS BECAUSE THE SMALL
LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN CARRYING
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A RENT IN ARREARS.
SINCE LAST SPRING AND THAT'S NO
SMALL NUMBER. AND SO THIS HELPS
ASSIST- THIS NEW MEASURE HOW
ASSURE THAT THEY LEAVE WHAT WE
A PER. OF THE DEATH TOLL TO
THEM AND IT HELPS KEEP TENANTS
HOW I MEAN AND THAT'S IN
BECAUSE AS OUR LOW KEEP STATING
IF THEY GOING TO FOR. NOT ONLY
THEY LEAVE THEIR PROPERTY AND
WILL NO LONGER BE HOLLOW SO WE
HAVE A MORE WORK TO DO- TO
THOSE ARE STRONG AND IT
INCLUDES THOSE WHO MAY NOT
QUALIFY BECAUSE THIS. THERE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS OF MANY
FOLKS MIGHT NOT QUALIFY SO AND
BUT THEY'RE STILL STRUGGLING IN
HIGH COST AREAS ON THE LAST-
THIS IS A GOOD AGREEMENT AND
IT'S THE RIGHT ACTION FOR THE
MOMENT. I SUPPORT IT ALSO WANT
TO THANK OUR PRO TEM FOR HER
EXCELLENT LEADERSHIP. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND I TRUST
THAT WE GET TO WERE OUT AS
STATED BY MANY OF OUR-COLLEAGUES TO EDUCATE. THE
PUBLIC BOTH THE TENANT AND THE
LANDLORDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE AND
IT GETS THE PEOPLE THAT THEY-
NEED SO. ON THAT NOTE I
STRONGLY ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD ST DOLE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBER A I TO
BE SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF THE
JUST QUICKLY TO A STATE SUMMER
OF ARKANSAS DURING THE BY
COMMITTEE AND THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM A AND ALL THIS FROM SAN
JOSE MENTIONED- THE CALL WICKS
QUITE FOR. WHEN WE SAW THE CARE
ACT MONIES CAN OUT ARRAY IN THE
FOR ROUND WE KNOW THAT- PEOPLE
IN RULE AREAS GOT EIGHTY TWO
DOLLARS AND THAT NUMBER WAS
ALMOST DOUBLE IN THE URBAN
AREAS SO I ASKED ACTUALLY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DURING
OUR A BUDGET HEARING WHAT THE
PLAN WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THESE WERE DISTRIBUTED- FAIRLY
IN EQUITY B. AND THE ANSWER I
GOT WAS NOT REALLY- VERY-
CONFIRMING THAT THE FACT THAT
MIGHT BE DATA RIGHT AND I ASKED
A- SO I JUST WANT TO SAY TO
THE- THE BODY HERE. WE DON'T
WATCH AND HOLD THEIR FEET TO
THE FIRE THERE'S BEEN ANY
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
THAT I'M SURE ALL OF YOU HAVE
HAD CALLS TO YOUR OFFICE ET DE
VACCINES AT THIS POINT RIGHT
NOW SO I JUST WOULD SHARE I
WANNA SUPPORTERS LEGISLATION
THINK IT'S VERY MUCH NEEDED BUT
I ALSO WANT TO STATE THE FACT
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED IN A IN A PROPER
EQUITY WAY- THAT WORKS FOR ALL
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY CENTER. NIELSEN MATTER
PRESENT GLAZER ON SENATE A-
QUICKLY. IF I. OF THE AUTHOR-
MADAM CHAIR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY LACK IN
THE BILL THAT WOULD IN THE
RIGHT OF. TO BASED ON CALL FOR
EXAMPLE HEALTH SINCE IS
DESTRUCTION OF. SENATE SKINNER
BEFORE A NEIL START I TRIED TO
ASK IF YOU TAKE A CO WE TAKE A-
YES I WILL THANK YOU AND YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. THANK YOU-
CENTER NIELSEN GIVE IF YOU THE
QUESTION. OKAY I AND AS I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE INTO OF THE
BILL AND I BE SO OF THE BILL
BUT QUESTION IS THERE ANY HERE
THAT IN. THE WAY. OF LAND TO
THE- BASED ON COMMENTS BECAUSE
MEETINGS AS THIS OF PROPERTY
AND SAY IS THAT THE HAS.
EFFECTED AS A IN OF THAT
PROPERTY THEY. FICTION
PROTECTIONS FOR OTHER REASONS
BUT COUNTY WHICH DO YOU PREFER
A LIGHTER TONIGHT OF. THANK YOU
CENTER NELSON MEMBER SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR SKINNER PLEASE CALL US.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE'VE
HAD I FELT A VERY- GOOD AND
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT- KNOWING
THAT WE HAVE A TIME BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN IT EXPIRES JUNE
THIRTIETH. TO MAKE ANY. ACTIONS
IF SO NEEDED AND IN THE
MEANTIME I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
FIVE BECKER. I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABRERO I CORTESE
HI DALLY I DODD FIVE TO RAZA
FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER. FIVE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO HI- TADO I JONES.
LAYERED I LEYVA I LIMóN
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN HI A CHIRLA
BOTH. I PAN. FIVE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE STERN. UMBERG HI WE
CASTING HI WIENER FIVE WILK HI.
SENATOR MOVES A POL MEMBERS
GIVE US JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE
THREE BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL
AND WE NEED TO GET A COUPLE
SENATORS BACK DOWN TO THE FLOOR.
REMEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL ON THREE BILLS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. TWENTY
NINE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR
JUST. DALLY GLAZER I LIMóN
STERN HI. FIVE TWENTY NINE
THOSE SIX ON THE URGENCY. THE
DALAI DID YOU VOTE NO. THANK
YOU SIR. DALLY NO. OKAY I
TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN ON THE
URGENCY TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN TH
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B.
EIGHTY NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER AYE LIMóN STERN HI.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SIX SB
NINETY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE JONES.
LIMóN MELENDEZ. STERN HI. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE EXCUSE ME I THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SEEING
NONE ALTHOUGH I DO THINK BE A
FRONT RULES COMMITTEE IS
MEETING- IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE MEDIALLY FOLLOWING OUR
FLOOR SESSION AND SENATE
NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE CONDITION THE FILE PLEASE
PROCEED. SENATE PRESIDENT LAYS
DOWN THE SENATE YEAH. I WOULD
THE- LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION AND TO YOUR CONCERN.
A CONTRACTOR HAS BEEN LEFT TO
CREATE A THIRD PARTY TO
ADMINISTER THE COLORED.
DISSEMINATION OF ACTIONS. I AM
OF THE OPINION THAT THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA. BUT WHAT CONCERNS ME
IS THE LACK OF ACCESS. FOR US
TO REVIEW THE CONTRACT THE
PROVISION IN THE CONTRACT ARE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. AND PUT TO
MANY YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE CONTRACTS
WITH MAJOR SUPPLIERS
PARTICULARLY HIGH TECH
SUPPLIERS. THAT HAVE COST US
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS NOT COME IN
ON TIME AND HAVE CRASHED AND
BURNED. SO I AM CONCERNED OF
THE PROVISIONS I HAD NO
MISTRUST OF THOSE WHO
APPARENTLY HAVE RECEIVED THE
APPROVAL OF THE CONTRACT. BUT
SUFFICE TO SAY IT IS CERTAINLY
BEEN A RUSH DEAL. WE DON'T KNOW
IF THERE WAS A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL PLACED FOR THIS OR NOT
WHAT WAS THE EXPECTATION AND
THE CURRENT CRITERIA PUT FORTH
BY THE STATE TO THE APPLICANTS
FOR THE CONTRACTS. AND WHAT
WERE OF THE FINAL PROVISIONS IN
THE CONTRACT TO ASSURE THAT THE
STATE. IS LEGALLY PROTECTED SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE OF THAT
TO BE AWARE I HAVE A QUESTION
OR FACT DEMANDED. THAT CONTRACT
TO THE REVIEW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON MEMBERS AS
YOU EXIT THE FLOOR. IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER AT THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY FLOOR
SESSION- THE NEXT ONE IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY FEBRUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO
PM. THANK YOU MADAM HOTEL THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MNDAY AT TWO
PM. HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND MEMBERS.